The first thing you have to do is figure out that this is actually a product.
It's #5. Because you have multiple data points, the probabilities multiply.
Going to the logarithm, we replace it with a sum that is #6.
And the logarithm of the expression in the exponent is just its argument
which means #3 is the solution here.
You simply just copy those argument over.
The first derivative loses all of these terms over here. They don't depend on µ.
But it would change this one over here.
The answer ends up being 4, Xi-µ/σ² and the reason is the way the derivative works.
We take the derivative of this expression.
There's a 2 over here that gets multipled left and a minus sign in front of the µ.
Those get multiplied in and then canceled out with -1/2.
Now from here to here, I just multiplied with σ²and now I bring the µ out
and import this and the resulting expression is Nµ.
The N comes in because we have N additions of µ in the formula over here.
That completes the entire proof.